thank you welcome back remember ladies
and gentlemen nobody goes home
empty-handed tonight's the losers all
receive the new Oscar home game and now
to present the nominees for film editing
an actor who has just finished directing
his first picture entitled hot stuff and
an actress who could easily have played
the title role
Dom DeLuise and valerie perrine
here at the Academy Awards I tell you
Valerie it's very strange that the
Academy would ask me of all people to
help with the editing award well because
editors hate me my performance and films
are so impeccable that there's no need
for them to edit a hole definitely I
mean definitely can we take that again
please and I know I can get it right
shall we go on with the nominees
absolutely oh all right there are very
outstanding for achievement in film
editing Robert East Wing boys from
Brazil he does Jenna the deer hunter
gerry hambling the Midnight Express
Stewart Baird Superman Peters dinner for
the dear ha
many years ago when I was a student
Austria
I used to indulge in the recurring
fantasy that one day I would stand on
the stage like this and received this
wonderful famous statuette tonight I
would like to thank the America American
Catholic Academy the members for turning
this fantasy into reality thank you very
much